als hier im dezember für deutschlands
politik die zukunft beginnt ist auch
viel vergangenheit im raum auch der
deutschen russlandpolitik frank walter
steinmeier war schon als schröders
kanzleramtschef dabei dann als merkels
außenminister zweimal gleich und auch
als bundespräsident blieb er
brückenbauer nach moskau letztes jahr
noch nannte er die energiebeziehungen
die fast letzte brücke zwischen russland
und europa nutzten zwei also nicht als
abhängigkeits verstärker sondern als
friedensprojekt es sollte uns alle
erstens ein vorwurf machen aber zweitens
in deutschland besonders meinte man dass
die geschichte zu ende sei und vor allem
die spd meinte man könnte mit
friedenspolitik und nicht mit
sicherheitspolitik die zukunft zukunft
deutschlands sichern so klingen viele
dieser tage in berlin scharfe kritik am
bundespräsidenten gibt kaum jemand wohl
aber in seiner langjährigen politik
meist mit verweis auf andere
wir haben uns energiepolitisch
faktisch von russland in eine viel zu
hohem maße abhängig gemacht weil wir
eine illusion hinterher gerannt sind die
illusion hieß es gibt keine abhängigkeit
weil wir gegenseitig abhängig sind in
der tat setzen viele auf dialog aber
niemand so leidenschaftlich so
ausdauernd wie frank walter steinmeier
heißt es selbst im auswärtigen amt ob
bei der sogenannten
modernisierungspartnerschaft mit
russland dann bei verhandlungen dem
majdan rat etwa oder später in minsk
aber auch noch lange danach dabei hatte
es warnsignale gegeben zuhauf 2000
tschetschenien 28 georgien 214 die krim
danach der don was die bomben in syrien
der tiergarten mords die vergiftung
navalny
scannt man muss sich den vorwurf machen
lassen dass er das dieses stoppschild
nicht gesehen hat und und auch nicht
darauf reagiert hat und russland hat
einfach weitergemacht ja also letztlich
ist es wirklich eine eine ignoranz einer
einer realität russische politik und
auch von von stopp schildern die
gardinen die die irgendwann auch zu
einer anpassung der eigenen haltung
analyse und und auch politik hätten
führen müssen
214 sei durchaus auch für ihn ein
wendepunkt gewesen heißt es aus
steinmeiers umfeld so habe er fortan
etwa für das zwei prozent ziel der nato
gekämpft gegen die eigene partei in
erinnerung aber blieben andere aussagen
zu 16 etwa warnte er vor symbolischen
panzer paraden und davor durch laute
säbelrasseln und kriegs goll die lage
weiter anzuheizen er meinte nicht putin
damals sondern die nato
putin sei nicht daran interessiert unser
partner zu sein hatte kurz zuvor john
mccain gewarnt syrien betrachtet er als
übungsgelände flüchtlingskrise wolle
eher anheizen um die eu zu spalten das
ändere sich nur eins sein appetit nehme
zu je mehr ist zu zeigen
gespenstisch warf erscheinen diese worte
im rückblick steinmeier sagte damals
dies das zurückfallen in die alten
kategorien die wir gelernt haben wenn
die alten feindbilder
das hilft uns nicht weiter die ost und
friedenspolitik ist ja nicht dadurch
falsch dass putin die st angriffskrieg
gestartet hat und deswegen halte ich von
der debatte alles sei falsch gewesen die
friedenspolitik falsch die ostpolitik
falsch das ist soll man so ein bisschen
die nachträgliche besserwisserei
nachverhandlungen schrieb steinmeier
später habe sich öfters noch mit sergey
lavrov getroffen auf einen scotch
insgesamt habe er eine doppelstrategie
gefahren heißt es aus seinem umfeld
dialog und härte sowohl als auch
also selbst wenn eine doppelstrategie
gefahren hätte war diese dieser dieser
teil sozusagen der kooperation des
entgegenkommens gegenüber russland immer
der dominante teil und und die hatte
habe ich zumindest nicht gesehen aber
ich glaube die hat die russische führung
auch nicht gesehen auch er hat sie nicht
gesehen der ukrainische botschafter
liegt mit bild über kreuz nicht erst
seit heute auch nicht erst seit er ein
konzert boykottierte letzte woche
sondern spätestens seit steinmeier
letztes jahr für nur 2 watt und dabei
auch auf die geschichte mit russland
verwies samt des deutschen überfalls auf
die sowjetunion für viele ukrainer sei
das ein affront gewesen in doppelter
hinsicht
weil erstens die ukraine teil der
sowjetunion war sie hatte an diesem
deutschen vernichtungskrieg millionen
opfer zu beklagen und weil zweitens nord
stream 2 von anfang an als anti
ukrainisches projekt just als geplant
war und in diesem zusammenhang auf die
sowjetischen opfer zu verweisen ist
inakzeptabel nicht mehr aus ukrainischer
sicht heute mit blick auf butscher
sprach steinmeier explizit von
kriegsverbrechen am tag seiner
wiederwahl hatte er zudem schon diesen
appell an putin gerichtet lösen sie die
schlinge um den hals der ukraine suchen
sie mit uns einen weg der frieden in
europa bewahrt ein kräftiges signal an
putin sei das gewesen sagte wie aber
kein fehler ein geständnis hallt es
diese woche zurück schweigen in eigener
sache titelt die süddeutsche fehlt ihm
der mut fragt der spiegel vor gut einer
woche schickt frank walter steinmeier
einen brief nach russland an die uni
jekaterinburg lange war er der ihn
verbunden nun weil er seine
ehrendoktorwürde zurückgeben teil der
mit vier zeilen umfasst sein schreiben
eine begründung nennt er nicht
[Musik]